we are asked what could be the equation
of P and we have the graph of our
polynomial P right over here you could
view this as the graph of y is equal to
P of X so pause this video and see if
you can figure that out
alright now let's work on this together
and you can see that all the choices
have P of X in factored form where it's
very easy to identify the zeros or the x
values that would make our polynomial
equal to 0 and we could also look at
this graph and we can see what the zeros
are this is where we're going to
intersect the x axis also known as the
x-intercepts so you can see when X is
equal to negative 4 we have a 0 because
our polynomial is 0 there so we know P
of negative 4 is equal to 0 we also know
that P of it looks like one and a half
or I could say 3 halves P of 3 halves is
equal to 0 and we also know that P of 3
is equal to 0 so let's look for an
expression where that is true and
because it's in factored form each of
the parts of the product will probably
make our polynomial 0 for one of these
zeros so let's see if in order for our
polynomial to be equal to 0 when X is
equal to negative 4 we probably want to
have a term that has an X plus 4 in it
or we want to have it I should say a
product that has an X plus 4 in it
because X plus 4 is equal to 0 when X is
equal to negative 4 well we have an X
plus 4 there and we have an X plus 4
there so I'm liking choices B and D so
far now for this second root we have P
of 3 halves is equal to 0 so I would
look for something like X minus 3 halves
in our product I don't see an X minus 3
halves here but as we've mentioned in
other videos you can also multiply these
times constants so if I were to multiply
let's see if our to get rid of this
fraction here if I multiply by 2 this
would be the same thing as let me scroll
down a little bit same thing as 2x minus
3 and you could test that out 2x minus 3
is equal to 0 when X is equal to 3
halves
and let's see we have a 2x minus 3 right
over
so choice D is looking awfully good but
let's just verify it with this last one
for P of three to be equal to zero we
could have an expression like X minus
three in the product because this is
equal to zero when X is equal to three
and we indeed have that right over there
so choice D is looking very good when X
is equal to negative four this part of
our product is equal to zero which makes
the whole thing equal to zero when X is
equal to three halves two X minus three
is equal to zero which makes the entire
product equal to 0 and when exit - and
when an X is equal to 3 it makes X minus
3 equals to 0 0 times something times
something is going to be equal to 0